Democratic presidential candidate Bernie
Sanders recently received the final
dollars that he needed to break a really
really interesting milestone when it
comes to campaign fundraising he
officially hit two million individual
campaign contributions no other US
presidential candidate has achieved this
at this point in the election and to
contextualize this President Barack
Obama in 2008 historic campaign bringing
in so many new voters managed to break
just 1 million contributions Bernie
Sanders already breaking the two million
contribution mark even more impressive
is the contribution average size as of a
few days ago the average donation to
Bernie Sanders was under thirty dollars
which means that millions of his
supporters are chipping in rather small
amounts and they're sort of two ways to
look at this one way as well because
it's small amount it doesn't matter that
you have two million subscribers you're
not going to a two million donors you're
not going to get the money you need the
other side of it as well you have so
many more people engaged everybody gets
one vote and that could really be a big
deal so very interesting milestone that
Bernie Sanders is reached oh yeah I'm
very happy for burning his campaign I
think it is more about engagement then
about the actual amount of money we're
talking about here because well let's
face it burning does not have the
connections that Hillary has no he
doesn't have the the political action
committees he doesn't have the Koch
brothers backing him so uh all he needs
is votes and if whatever he's doing is
working at good well the question is
will it matter in the end right the good
news is record for contributions
combined with record attendance at his
rallies this is adding credibility to
the idea of Bernie Sanders energizing
first-time voters people under 45 years
old independence in open primary States
to maybe show up and vote at 2008 Obama
levels which was quite a victory in and
of itself the bad news is the news you
know right Bernie Sanders is far behind
nationally and he's behind in many key
states and as we know the DNC seems to
have its hand on the scales for Hillary
Clinton what I'm sure of
that if Bernie Sanders were sort of
establishment approved candidate and he
reached a donation record we would be
hearing it about it on corporate media
corporate media does not care that
Bernie Sanders has reached a record of
donations you would think wow corporate
media reports on news for the people
right and you know people people are
donating to Bernie this is a big story
net corporate media doesn't seem to care
about the two million donations yeah and
they you know they probably did all
cover this but it's going to be about a
five to ten second mention once today
maybe and and that's it yeah so they can
say they covered it absolutely and they
they can get it on the record in maybe
10 seconds or or maybe put it on their
online blog or something like that hey
its corporate media they're covering it
we cannot rely on corporate media
anymore that's why it's so important
that we have strong independent media if
it's ever if it's ever been more clear
than now I don't know when